عندما كنا نتخذ قرارًا بشأن
الهندسة المعمارية ، أردنا أن نحضر
شيئًا نموذجيًا للغاية وما
هو أكثر اكتمالًا من الثلج ،
لذلك قررنا إحضار الثلج هنا
واسم جناحنا ليس رأسًا ،
ثم أردنا دمج ذلك مع
الثقافة العربية لذلك نحن  قررنا إنشاء
خيمة عربية تطل على مدخل جناح الرأس الثلجي الخاص بنا
، وهذا يوصلنا
رسالة مفادها أننا هنا لبناء
جسور بين فنلندا ودولنا العربية ،
هذه المباني في المعرض هي
هياكل مؤقتة والاستدامة
عنصر مهم جدًا بالنسبة لنا ، لذا فإن أحد
المبادئ التوجيهية الرئيسية  في الهندسة المعمارية ، كانت
الاستدامة هي أنه يمكن بناء هذا المبنى
وتفكيكه
بسهولة
ويمكن بناؤه في مكان آخر لاحقًا
لاستخدام أطول ،
فالمبنى في الواقع عبارة عن
هيكل فولاذي بسيط للغاية ومن ثم يتم تغطية كل شيء
بنسيج بولي كلوريد الفينيل مما
يجعله يبدو وكأنه رأس ثلجي
في الداخل ، تركنا معظم
الهياكل مرئية ، لذلك لدينا
مظهر صناعي في الجناح
في المعرض ، فأنت دائمًا ما تكون  عند البحث عن
شيء تبرز من بين
الحشود ،
يوجد 191 جناحًا هنا ،
الخانق هو
مكاننا الخاص ،
إنه مكان لا يمتلكه أي شخص آخر
[موسيقى] ،
إنه في الواقع عكس المعرض تمامًا
، ولا توجد أي عروض لتثبت
عينيك على أرضيات الجرانيت فقط
والخشب على طول الطريق حتى ارتفاع 15
مترًا
ثم
لا شيء آخر ،
ثم لدينا مشهد صوتي يجمع
أصوات الطبيعة الفنلندية جنبًا إلى جنب مع
العناصر الآلية
ويمنحك فرصة للذهاب في رحلة سمعية
إلى حديقة وطنية فنلندية
.  مكان للهدوء هو
واحة حيث يمكنك أن تأتي وتسترخي
وتخفض ضربات قلبك وضغط الدم
[موسيقى]
عندما تأتي إلى قاعة المعرض في
جناح فنلندا ، سوف تتعرف
على موضوعنا الرئيسي وهو
مشاركة السعادة المستقبلية ثم على
المستوى البشري لدينا
يوجد 30 35 فتحة في الجناح
ويمكن لكل شخص التوقف ودراسة
الموضوعات التي يهتمون بها في
عنصر واحد.  الجناح الفنلندي هو
أن لديك تدفقًا حرًا للحركة
هناك ،
وهذا يخبرنا عن التفكير النهائي
بأنك حر في الذهاب كما يحلو لك ،
ويمكن للناس القدوم واستكشاف الأشياء
التي يهتمون بها
والانغماس في عناصر التعايش
بين الناس
تكنولوجيا الطبيعة وهلم جرا